I was trying to figure out why some
areas of my life I have high discipline
the discipline equation that I came up
with was at the start of the equation
you have the why oh yes the reason for
doing it so you just gave a list of y's
there plus the psychological enjoyment
you get from the pursuit itself yeah
minus the psychological disengagement or
unenjoyment that you get from the
pursuit even in the case of writing that
book you said like it was it was
incredibly unengaging and unenjoyable so
that part of the equation rose up the
enjoyment part Rose down but the bit
that you managed to get back up again
was the Y part of the equation yeah so
you go like if you said like y plus
enjoyment plus I know friction yeah
um I constantly think about ways in
areas of my life that I can remind
myself of why I'm doing this thing I can
make the pursuit of the thing as
enjoyable and frictionless as possible
and I can limit the discomfort and
friction of the pursuit of the thing and
that's why I think I've come to learn in
my life but the things I'm disciplined
on are when the why and the pursuit are
there and the friction is low